you're one of those performers that
could be someone could misconstrue
someone who was able to go out and sing
the way you can and command a stage like
that they might think Kristin Chenoweth
is a crescendo with is a diva do you get
that ever to people do people assume the
IRRI diva
just because you you in are in the
theater world and you're that
accomplished there is a misconception
but you know me you know me you know I
like like chain food restaurants and
like malls I love a good food court like
I loved it even me and now I will add
that question
beg I begged it up myself this week and
I was watching that running wild with
Bear Grylls yeah where they take
celebrities and they take them out and
the drop them in the middle of let's say
Africa and with no gates and there's
elephants right there and he makes them
squeeze that wasn't done and then drink
the choose truth julianne hough had to
do it and I thought I don't think I
would I don't think I might be a diva in
this position
refusing to drink the juice that is
extracted from elephant dung is not the
diva category she's difficult
she wouldn't drink that [ __ ] you think
there I could do terrain I could
probably do terrain but I have vertigo
so probably no I can't no no you
shouldn't no I'm saying no one should go
on those shows I have no interest in
going on a show where my manhood is
tested because I will tell them right up
front it's not going to go since you
brought it up bare I'm not sure how he
says it last night
Gorillaz oh I think it's girls it's just
great yeah bro that's the Bear Grylls
camera right there I would like to take
you to the mall on Black Friday and see
how you survive
somebody actually really funny that
would be that would be a hilarious
segment I know how to get an item if a
woman went I was at I call it forever 51
but I was at forever 21 and I saw a
woman with a hat a cute little beanie
and I said I've wanted a hat she was
looking at looking at looking at it and
I said what the Hat so I wonder when I
go oh no it has a hole she dropped it I
took it and bought it
I sure terrible person
[Applause]